seguramente ya han escuchado sobre las
células madre y quizás sepan que cada
célula de nuestro cuerpo ya sea una
célula muscular una célula nerviosa una
célula epitelial o una célula de
glóbulos rojos vienen de un mismo grupo
de células madre durante la etapa de
desarrollo por lo que todas estas
células diferenciadas como esta célula
muscular que tiene proteínas
contráctiles o como esta célula nerviosa
que puede enviar señales como esta
célula epitelial que es a prueba de agua
o como este glóbulo rojo que lleva
oxígeno
todas estas células vinieron de células
madre las cuales no tienen
diferenciación alguna como es posible
que ocurra esto es algo muy interesante
pero primero veamos una analogía
imaginen una biblioteca como la que
solías visitar de joven para investigar
sobre los temas escolares tiene todos
los libros que puedas imaginar pero
dependiendo de los libros que tú saques
y leas tus ideas y conocimientos van a
cambiar y serán diferentes de aquellos
que tienen otra
que ha leído libros distintos a los que
tú leíste pero todos los libros que
ambos leyeron se encuentran en esta
biblioteca nuestros genes y adn tienen
un sistema similar recuerda que dentro
del núcleo de cada célula está el adn
esta es nuestra biblioteca nuestro
conjunto de instrucciones genéticas para
construir por completo nuestro cuerpo
dentro de la biblioteca de nuestro adn
tenemos nuestros libros que son los
segmentos del adn que llamamos genes los
genes nos dan instrucciones específicas
sobre cómo hacer diferentes tipos de
proteínas y al tener diferentes tipos de
proteínas hace que cambie la forma en
cómo lucen y actúan nuestras células
dándoles habilidades diferentes con
excepción de la célula del glóbulo rojo
que carece del núcleo cada célula
somática en nuestro cuerpo tiene
exactamente el mismo adn sin embargo
esta célula muscular luce y se comporta
de forma diferente a esta neurona de
aquí y esto se debe a que están leyendo
libros diferentes de la biblioteca de
nuestro adn
usan genes diferentes para hacer sus
proteínas veamos un poco de terminología
cuando una célula usa activamente
ciertos genes se dice que está
expresando esos genes y cuando se está
expresando un gen se dice que está
encendido si el gen no se está
expresando se dice que está apagado
tengan esto en mente porque estamos
hablando de todo esto porque al final
todo se relaciona sobre cómo las células
madre terminan diferenciándose en las
células diferenciadas de aquí abajo el
punto importante es que para poder
diferenciarse por ejemplo para que una
célula madre pueda especializarse como
una célula muscular la célula madre debe
de encender el gen de la célula muscular
aquí está el adn y estoy resaltando el
gen de la célula muscular que se está
encendiendo en este momento
al mismo tiempo apaga otros genes al
encender los genes de la célula muscular
se producen proteínas dentro de la
célula que van a cambiar la apariencia
de esta ahora luce un poco más
y también van a cambiar sus funciones
ahora esta célula tiene proteínas
contráctiles las cuales ayudarán a
moverse a esta célula muscular en el
caso de la neurona la célula madre
enciende sus genes de neurona que estoy
señalando aquí apaga otros genes para
poder comenzar a producir las proteínas
necesarias para convertirse en una
neurona como las proteínas que le
permiten alargarse y generar estas ramas
picudas que vemos aquí llamadas
dendritas permítanme comentar que las
células madre de aquí son pluripotentes
es decir que pueden transformarse en
cualquiera de las células somáticas de
nuestro cuerpo adulto pero una vez que
se especializan en alguna de estas
células somáticas maduras ya no pueden
diferenciarse como otro tipo de células
y tampoco pueden diferenciarse es decir
no pueden regresar a hacer células
madres nuevamente al menos no en
nosotros los humanos estas células
permanecen así para formar nuestros
cuerpos seguramente ahora se preguntan
qué determina cuáles genes en ciertas
células se encienden o se apagan
en otras palabras cómo es que las
células sabe en qué momento debe
especializarse como un tipo diferente de
célula resulta que las células deciden
en qué se deben especializar con base en
ciertas indicaciones que reciben estas
indicaciones o señales pueden venir de
su ambiente interno o de su ambiente
externo permítanme mostrarles dos formas
en las que ocurre esto durante el
desarrollo de diversos organismos
incluyendo a los humanos comenzamos como
una sola célula llamada cigoto y el
cigoto tiene varias proteínas llamadas
factores de transcripción que flotan en
el citoplasma y también están los
precursores de estos factores de
transcripción pequeños pedazos de rn m
aquí hay dos cosas importantes primero
los factores de transcripción van a
activar a los genes y los van a encender
pues eso es lo que hacen los factores de
transcripción y segundo noten que todos
estos factores de transcripción están
agrupados en un área esto es importante
porque cuando el cigoto comienza a
dividirse en donde quedarán estos
factores detrás
como pueden ver aquí van a quedar en
aquellas células que se dividieron
dentro de esta región en donde se
ubicaban las células de aquí arriba casi
no tienen estos factores pero las
células de aquí abajo tienen muchos
factores de transcripción ahora pueden
imaginarse que diversos genes se van a
activar en estas células diferentes y
determinarán en qué se especializarán
estas células ya que ahora podrán
producir proteínas diferentes a este
mecanismo de aquí se le llama
apropiadamente segregación asimétrica de
determinantes celulares vaya a un nombre
tan largo pero vamos a verlo por partes
lo de asimétrico se refiere a que estos
factores de transcripción no quedan
distribuidos simétricamente entre las
células divididas de aquí la parte de
determinantes celulares se refiere a los
factores de transcripción y sus
precursores esta es una de las formas en
las que las células pueden diferenciarse
para formar cosas diferentes teniendo
alrededor diferentes factores de
transcripción la segunda forma de
especialización que mencionamos se
conoce como señalización de inducción o
simplemente induce
la inducción es como una gran influencia
como la presión social de las personas
que nos rodean en donde una célula o
grupo de células pueden inducir a otro
grupo de células a que se diferencien
usando solamente señales las señales
pueden transmitirse de distintas formas
por difusión que es cuando son liberadas
por un grupo y se difunden hacia otro
grupo y llegan a los receptores de este
último causando que se diferencien las
células de éste o también puede darse la
inducción por contacto directo entre
células podemos ver estas proteínas en
las superficies de estas células en
contacto directo una tercera forma es
tener señales que pasan a través de
uniones en hendidura que son pequeñas
conexiones entre células esto puede
inducir a una célula a diferenciarse en
la biología celular tenemos estas
proteínas konex y nash que forman una
unión y colectivamente las llamamos
conexiones la inducción es una forma
clave para el desarrollo de las
diferentes partes de nuestro cuerpo
nuestras extremidades se forman
parcialmente debido a la inducción
también
los ojos y nuestros oídos así como
muchas otras partes de nuestro cuerpo se
forman en la etapa embrionaria debido a
la inducción es por eso que la inducción
es tan importante en la diferenciación
celular teniendo esto en mente les
recuerdo que la meta con estos
determinantes y top las micos en estos
factores de transcripción que
mencionamos al principio y las señales
que mencionamos en la inducción es
cambiar la expresión del gen encender o
apagar ciertos genes lo que finalmente
ocasiona que las células se diferencie
en otras células más especializadas